earlier today I was taking a walk along
a portion of the Hank Aaron Trail here
in the downtown of Milwaukee or properly
speaking not quite in the downtown but a
bit South and to the west of it in a
place that we call the Menominee River
Valley and I chose a section of it that
I knew would be a great walk not just
for exercise and for getting out of the
apartment but because I knew from
experience just how many flowers would
be in bloom this time of year because
I've gone on that path quite a few times
particularly since the covid lockdown I
would get outside and take walks for
exercise and generally there's very few
people along that portion of the Hank
Aaron Trail and it got me thinking about
something that I I you know I decided I
would shoot a video discussing and
instead of like having one single
particular story that I am going to tell
you it's going to be a bit broader here
and it just has to do with the general
topic of flowers and I'm somebody who
really loves the color and the shapes
and the scents and the arrangements and
beauty of flowers particularly those
that grow wild or are planted in gardens
and so you know where did that actually
come from well I was kind of
fortunate in when I grew up and who I
grew up with you know I was born in 1970
and I grew up out in you know a
subdivision that took a long time to
fill in called the hills of Delafield
which was in the town of or the township
rather of Delafield but actually closer
to the Village of Wales and
um you know there were prairies and
woods and hills and even Rock piles all
over the place and because of that there
were many flowers growing wild and I you
know picked them and appreciated them
and we also had lots and lots of Gardens
and flower beds planted not least
because my mother
really like flowers herself and given
the you know let's call it the uh
opportunity to plant a bunch of things
you know we had about an acre of yard
that we progressively landscaped into
different things my dad was much more
into trees and bushes and the grass he
he uh a significant expense bought sod
for the front yard and rolled it all out
but my mom was very much about the
flowers
and you know where did that come from
well in part I think from my uncle
Hubert who I've shot you know a video
discussing before who was just an
amazing gardener he loved flowers
himself and planted all sorts of flowers
everywhere that he lived and when they
retired to Indiana which I've talked
about before Shayla Marie's the lemrez
compound out in Northwestern Indiana
where my grandfather and grandmother and
Uncle Hubert and Aunt Therese and my
uncle Ernest and his his wife Betty all
put their retirement homes prefab Wausau
homes basically the same thing just with
different Decor plunked them down and
lived there more or less the rest of
their lives although Ernie ended up
uh while Ernie died and Betty moved to
back to the city
um
they had all sorts of scope for planting
things and Uncle Hubert would have all
of these catalogs some of them were seed
catalogs some of them were bulb catalogs
there were cuttings that he would do
here and there and it's very interesting
you know it wasn't just flowers it was
also berries and
um trees and bushes you know he he
actually took lilacs transplanted them
from the family farm which they had sold
and brought them to you know the the new
place and then put them into the soil
and he could grow just about anything so
my mother I think was very influenced by
that they each had their favorites Uncle
Yuber could grow roses and you know put
all this work and time into them and and
knew exactly what was needed for each of
them and I mean I never got to that sort
of level but he also planted lilies
everywhere of different sorts and irises
and uh all sorts well tulips and all
sorts of other beautiful flowering
plants so the yard was his yard well and
everybody else's yard because he'd plant
in theirs too it was just full at
different times of the year with
beautiful
um domesticated flowers of all sorts and
my mom did that where we grew up as well
you know I remember there were the
annuals that she would purchase and you
know have outside like begonias and
gardenias and things like that but she
also also planted all sorts of bulbs so
there were tulips everywhere and she
brought us kids in on it you know when
she would plant things she would tell us
what she was doing she would explain it
to us we would be part of the process we
would get to see the things growing she
had beautiful daffodils so Springtime
was quite wonderful and then we had you
know Lilies of different sorts and
irises but the thing that she really
loved the most that I remember
were peonies that you know big showy
flowers that actually ants will come on
and you know bite away at the um the big
flower
Buds and allow them to open up I used to
actually like spray the ants off until
she told me knock it off they you need
those ants and and those are beautiful
showy very fragrant flowers those are
around the back of the house where they
would get good sunlight
but the thing that I really love the
most of the things that she planted and
put so much time and Karen love into
were the snapdragons
now you know we have native snapdragons
that grow here in Wisconsin and
throughout the Midwest and they tend to
be yellowish and their heads are a
little bit small but the domesticated
snapdragons you can get in all sorts of
colors and the heads are big and you can
pinch them and their mouth actually
opens up that's why they're Snap Dragons
and we would pick all sorts of these and
we would cut them you know we had other
things too gladiolas that you would cut
at certain times of the year and so you
know that was just part of how I grew up
and really every place that we moved to
there were certain plants that we had
flowering and it was part of what it was
to have a a house and a yard and a
garden
now I mentioned that there were all
sorts of wildflowers and this is where
we get to things that were favorites
both of mine but also of my grandmother
on my dad's side uh Grandma Sadler whose
favorite flower was the one that bore
her name Queen Anne's Lace her name was
Anne and she said that that was her
favorite flower that's something that
you find a lot here in the Midwest as
well it's you know sort of a wild carrot
big showy white flowers
sometimes with a little purple tiny bit
in the middle and you can cut them
they're great for you know Wildflower
bouquets quite beautiful
lots of other things that grow wild as
well including tiger lilies and clover
daisies black eyed Susans who my aunt
Susan my grandmother's sister that was
that was her favorite flower I think you
see a theme here they like flowers that
had their name right
and there would be just all sorts of
interesting beautiful flowers and if one
wasn't flowering well another one would
be and a lot of these we gave weird
names to you know there was one that we
called skunk weed because it didn't
smell particularly good I'm not sure
what its actual name is but we would
pick all of these and you know cut them
sometimes in some places there would be
violets that had escaped and go on go on
Rogue in people's yards and so you know
it was quite common to go out in you
know the summer or even in the spring or
the fall depending on what was blooming
and just cut beautiful bouquets and
bring them inside I remember as a kid we
very frequently would have flowers that
weren't bought in any store they came
from either the Garden or from walks it
would take out in the Prairies The
Meadows the woods and there were even
flowers that were kind of unusual that
you didn't find too often and when we
did it was kind of a big deal there was
one type that would only grow in a
certain place in the woods on a hill and
we would carefully keep everyone away
from it because we wanted it to go to
seed it was it was small but beautiful
and showy and so I grew up with flowers
and I actually considered at one point
in time a job
like a career
with that that may be surprising to some
of you when I was in high school they
made us take these not aptitude tests
but more like what you were what you
might be interested in doing
and
um you know mine were kind of all over
the map I remember archaeologists was
one of the things I wanted to be
probably because of watching Indiana
Jones and you know shows like that and
thinking that'd be really cool I
probably would have enjoyed archeology
and I don't remember with the other you
got five things I don't remember what
the other three were but florist was one
of them and it wasn't something that I'd
like sat down and picked but it was
given to me in the test results the
guidance counselor was like this is some
weird stuff you know and I thought yeah
maybe maybe I would like to be a florist
I mean I'd get to see beautiful flowers
all the time I like the way a lot of
them smell I like uh you know putting
them together in certain Arrangements
aesthetically there's lots of ways to do
that that could be a pretty good life
and I never did pursue that I never
actually worked as a florist but I did
uh do a lot of gardening you know
I ended up using my inheritance to buy
the house that had belonged to Uncle
Hubert and Aunt Therese
and that's where I moved uh my my family
to onto family land and then I began
reworking that you know the lilacs and I
love lilacs they were all overgrown with
invasive plants like Autumn Olive which
has some nice flowers but you you know
it's invasive so you got to cut it down
and I put so much work and time and
labor and thought into cultivating all
of these these things and to find them
you know perhaps out in the woods I'd
pirate flowers and plants and eventually
I built it up quite nicely so there was
always something beautiful blooming from
the very beginnings of spring with
crocuses and grape hyacinths and
anemones and you know squib and things
like that to daffodils to irises to
lilies to lily of the valley to pick
whatever else you you want
but I I did this you know before I
actually moved to Indiana I uh once I
actually had you know a place of my own
for example when I was in graduate
school down in Southern Illinois and
Carbondale very different growing season
down there I would go around and pick
flowers of course like you know Bergamot
and Queens Anne's Lace and make myself
beautiful bouquets at home for myself
sometimes the cats would get into them
but I didn't get anything that was toxic
for them but I also grew flowers in the
yard that I had in that trailer park so
I had lilies everywhere I had a number
of different kinds of mints which if you
don't know they make beautiful flowers
as well real delicate things thyme
Russian sage you know I I would actually
go to the garden shop and like just look
around and be like oh that looks
interesting let me see if I can plant it
and make it grow I took bulbs so you
know I had all those things that I'd
mentioned before
um
daffodils narcissus
irises
you know
crocuses grape hyacinths all these
wonderful things in my yard which of
course most of which I I left there some
of which I did transplant from place to
place and I was a big as I mentioned
pyritter so if I saw you know if I was
riding a bike or driving my car and I
would see a bunch of flowers out there
in the drainage ditch somewhere and I
thought oh those look good I'd go and
dig them up I got a lot of lilies that
way a lot of irises that way
quite a few bergamots all sorts of other
interesting things sometimes they didn't
live but sometimes they would make it
sometimes they would actually reproduce
quite well
and so
you know once we move to uh Kingston
um I had a small bit of a garden uh our
landlords you know let us have a small
space and so I took a few plants and and
had them in there I haven't done a lot
of planting since we moved here to
Milwaukee but I get to appreciate the
beautiful flowers that I get to see
everywhere some of them are planted by
the city and every once in a while you
know like I'll pick some pansies and
bring them to my wife
um they're not enough for a bouquet or
anything but it's a way of brightening
both of our day with some color but you
know there's a lot of Green Space here
as well so you know this time of year
we've got the daisies In Bloom we've got
the Bergamot starting up we've got
lilies that are going to be coming in
catnip is going going like gangbusters I
used to when we still had sassy I would
go and pick wild catnip for her I
actually took her along on some of those
trips and we'd pick the catnip together
and catnip comes up with these beautiful
flowers which she liked to uh snack on
because it's catnip right so there's all
sorts of cool stuff towards the end of
the year it'll be you know less and less
stuff available but the snapdragons I
know where they are in this this town
and so I can go to the patches and pick
those and so there's there's usually
from late spring all the way to you know
early fall we've got beautiful flowers
that we can pick and beautiful places
that we can go to I began this by
talking about this portion of the Hank
Aaron Trail so let me see if I can
sketch this for you it's down along the
menomona a river so there's you know
seagulls flying overhead but there's
lots of other birds chirping away as
well and you walk along this path and
this time of year
there's quite a few bergamots
um it's we're sort of in between Daisy
and black-eyed Susan time so we've got
the end of the daisies black-eyed Susans
will just be coming in soon Bergamot or
also called bee balm is all over the
place there's all sorts of other cool
things you know tick weed they planted
some sunflowers and I see them sprouting
up they're not yet in bloom queensland's
lace everywhere yarrow all over the
place another beautiful white flower
with these feathery stems and those are
just a few you know so there's like a
carpet of white oh speaking of white a
bush Elderberry is in season right now
eventually once the flowers are actually
you know fertilized they're going to
turn into little purple Elder berries
but right now there are these giant
blooms
Lacy white
what would you call them colonies of
flowers so as you're walking along
you're seeing the butterfly weed the
orange of that and the yellow and the
purple and the pink and the white even a
few blue things here and there and it's
carpeted and then you'll see bees
buzzing around honeybees solitary bees
of different sorts big fat bumblebees
Gathering pollen and it's it's beautiful
and there's butterflies and other things
dragonflies of course flitting around
they don't need the pollen but they're
there to eat the other insects and so as
you walk along this you know maybe three
or four blocks space you've got flowers
on both sides of you and the Menominee
river flowing along right past them
beautiful and you can smell all these
different scents Mingle laying in the
air and so for me this is something I
like to do from time to time too immerse
myself in the sights in the sense and
the sounds of all of these profusions of
blooms and it takes me back in a certain
sense to my childhood you know every
year that you see the same species of
flowers obviously not the same flowers
although they may have the same root
structure blooming it's a reconnection
with what you grew up with
and so you know I'll just give you one
other example of that I'm fortunate in
that my wife has a mother who also loves
peonies and grows them in her yard and
every once in a while my wife will come
back she snipped some and we get to put
them in a vase and we've got this
beautiful smell and these you know
blooms these big thick fat blooms that
we can turn our eyes to every once in a
while and sort of linger over and you
know it reminds me of the peonies that
my mother grew or Uncle Uber grew or
other people grew so I've got a very
strong attachment I think as you can see
to flowers a real eye and proverbial
Green Thumb for them and there's
something that really is is important to
my my life and probably always will be
so long as I can see them and enjoy them
and I hope that at least for some of you
you get as much enjoyment out of flowers
as I have and continue to do